okay and finally new rules someone must
tell all the parents who now say that
the recent homeschooling
has left them with a new appreciation
for teachers
it's about time
[Music]
this week parents across america face
the harsh reality that after a spring
with the kids home all the time in a
summer with the kids home all the time
we may have a fall in winter with the
kids home all the time
which is not only nerve-racking it's
destroying mom's relationship with the
gardener
yeah summer is ending but for parents
summer was never the vacation
when the kids go back to school that's
the vacation
why do you think summer camp was
invented it wasn't to teach you survival
skills it was to get you out of the
house
they're calling online classrooms
distance learning
distance for who the kids are right
there at the kitchen table all damn day
distance is what schools were for
to
to provide a five day a week break from
having to deal with those little shits
on your christmas card
no wonder 69 percent of parents now say
that being a teacher is a harder job
than their own
and 80 say they have a newfound respect
for teachers
great
okay but how about we go beyond giving
teachers newfound respect
how about we also give them the benefit
of the doubt
ask any teacher what their number one
complaint is
and it's helicopter parents sticking
their noses in
doing their kids work for them trying to
adjust grades
and undermining discipline you have two
kids and you want to strangle them
can you imagine having to deal with an
entire classroom full of tiny sticky
strangers
it used to be the teacher would send
home a report card about the behavior of
the child now it's the behavior of the
teacher that gets
judged i've heard it from teachers many
times parents
saying things like but my daughter
studied really hard for this test
yeah but she got all the answers wrong
that's what matters in life results not
just trying
not just participating when everybody
gets a trophy the only people who win
are the people who make trophies
if children don't learn that life can be
full of disappointments they won't be
ready for
marriage or democrat primaries
if your kid gets a d don't blame the
teacher tell your child you should have
worked harder
you should have buckled down more now go
to your room and do whatever it is you
do there on your webcam
and the next time that there is a
classroom disagreement where a teacher
says one thing and your kid says another
side with the teacher i mark the onset
of american decline to the moment
parents started siding with their
children instead of with the teachers
seriously
kids may be cute but they're also
relentlessly manipulative little weasels
who can only be contained with a united
front
mom dad and the teacher used to form an
iron triangle a tight threesome like
jerry falwell his wife in the pool boy
kids couldn't get away with [ __ ] and
they were so much
healthier for it helicopter parenting or
bulldozer parenting whatever you want to
call it it isn't good for anybody
not the teachers not the parents not the
kids
and the idea that kids have too little
self-esteem it's antiquated
antiquated they have too much now and
it's turning them into
angry screaming grievance collectors and
all of that childhood tolerance is
resulting in grown-up tyrants
it's no wonder by the time they get to
college just having to listen to an
opinion they don't agree with
is considered an act of violence
oh yeah it doesn't even end when the
kids leave the house parents go on
job interviews with their kids now a
study a few years ago found that 30
percent
of employers had gotten resumes written
by the applicant's parents
15 reported fielding complaints from a
parent
when they didn't hire the kid and yet
somehow our economy is falling behind
china's weird huh
so if in the future a teacher takes your
kid's phone
just tell that teacher thank you thank
you for doing something
i lacked the balls to do years ago
you